[Music]
ice cream for me
okay
[Music]
would be no l.a food scene without the
street vendors you wouldn't have tacos
we wouldn't have hot dogs l.a hot dog
that's a trademark without street
vendors i wouldn't know about tamales
that are sold from the carts or elotes
that are so wonderful you'd never have
experienced that someone wants a late
night bite and they go to a carl's jr
and they may not realize that you know
carl's jean started as a street vendor
pink's hot dogs was a hot dog car and
look what happened they were able to
achieve their dreams but these
businesses are unicorns because our
policies
were working against them
so when these street fighters go out and
they're clamped down on that's
unthinkable because someone who is
trying to make an honest living
is being criminalized and is being
subjected to excessive force i will cite
you with the vehicle code of blocking
the sidewalk i will not give you any
more warnings cities are so eager and a
little bit trigger happy with these
citations for folks that are trying to
get into the system and trying to get
permits and trying to get approved carts
some of these entrepreneurs have to pay
30 to 40 000
just to get a chance to work without a
threat of harassment and what we are
advocating for is that the city and the
state look at this and say there has to
be a better way that these micro
entrepreneurs are not fronts for
gambling rings and they're not selling
drugs they're selling fruit cups because
they're trying to take care of their
families
hola my name is
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
a
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bueno
i'm good
[Music]
inclusive action is one of the founders
of the la street vendor campaign and
back in 2008 2009 we recognized that
street vending was illegal in los
angeles despite it being so iconic so
even though los angeles to finally
legalize street vending in 2018 we knew
that street food vendors had a different
layer of policy that they had to worry
about
[Music]
if i was a street food vendor that was
looking to get a permit in los angeles i
can go to the office and apply for one
but when they ask me what i'm selling if
i see them selling fruit they're going
to say oh great well can you show us
your public health department permit
they're going to require blueprints for
my car and thousands of dollars for the
new car and there's a lot of systems
that a street food vendor has to go
through because the california retail
food code isn't designed for them
one of the key characteristics of this
campaign is that it's led by street
vendors
when people say who's the leader of the
campaign it's kind of hard to say
because it really is a collective it's
caridad and it's merced
in
yolanda and meddling and these very
powerful vendor leaders that are working
every day on the sidewalk
they're superheroes
merced is a really thoughtful and also
passionate organizer and merced was
really critical leading up to the
legalization effort here in los angeles
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's go
the vendors used to be all along here
and then santa monica wanted to prohibit
them from entering the pier area so they
blocked this whole area off to the
public and the vendors
here's a space they could be setting up
right here
but
they've been kicked out
i was outraged by the fact that law
enforcement would go and take the
vendors last way to make a living you'd
come down here on a weekend and there
would be street food for you
and now
you're not a vendor in sight because as
soon as a vendor appears setting up
there law enforcement sweeps down
and they're ticketed and arrested
so the only vendors you're going to see
now are a few
like the man over there who's pulling
his goods along the sand because the law
requires that you have to keep moving
i'm here simply to to help these street
vendors who have been faced with
thousands and thousands of dollars in
fines
it's interesting how we think santa
monica is this liberal beacon yet when
it comes to street vendors people who
are brown or latino who may be
immigrants then those people are not
allowed they're picking and choosing who
is accepted into this community
black and brown entrepreneurs out here
that have been hustling for a long time
and have amazing ideas on how to
activate space and make spaces much more
dynamic we need to bring them in
education
my name is maria i'm a hot dog and corn
bender i've been bending in santa monica
for eight years already
today i don't have a cart because
the polices around the city is around
que nos da la policia
if they see us with the car
they find us and they throw away our
stuff it makes me upset because in a lot
of countries including mexico there's a
lot of people dying of having nothing to
eat and they're just getting here and
throwing everything to the trash even
the fruit everything waters sodas chips
everything
one of the city officers
came and tried to take my car out
when he pulled it he threw the oil on me
so i have the the marks right here when
he burned me
all i'm trying to do is to make money to
support my family my kids so this is
where we want to be
okay
i know she's leaving
so what you see behind me is the joint
law enforcement task force that the city
of santa monica is spending almost three
million dollars
over the next year and a half so that
the street vendors can be rounded up and
taken out of santa monica
here at the beach this vital part of our
culture has been taken away i can't
imagine
ever kids coming to the beach and then
not experiencing that street vendor food
of a hot dog or a fruit cup etc it's
part of the beach experience
so basically taking the vendors like
taking the culture with just wasting
money
honestly i don't understand the problem
i mean it's not right for her to leave
just just because i don't make money
and taking away their hustle is kind of
it's kind of messed up
i think in order for us to bring street
food vendors into our society we need
policies that
recognize them as entrepreneurs
that means we need to design our permit
systems in a way that they can actually
understand
and that encourages them to
participate what folks can do to help
the street vendors is call your city
council member and say please give the
street vendors a legal and safe place to
sell stop the law enforcement harassment
[Music]
[Music]
is
very good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you